Disney's wreckit-ralph was a veritable
Easter Eggstravaganza for video game
nerds especially those that spent half
their lives in the arcade during the 80s
and 90s here's a look at some of the
things in the film only adults will have
noticed there's a lot going on with the
two policeman characters introduced in
the sugar rush realm the pair serve the
tyrannical King candy meaning they're
pretty fast and loose with their use of
tasers and batons which reads a bit like
a statement in itself especially when
factoring in the surge protectors random
screening stops with Ralph's
random Security check random I behind
you always stop me I'm just a surge
protector doing my job sir not to
mention their motto is to heat and serve
which is pretty close to the usual law
enforcement credo of to protect and
serve
on a lighter note they're also shaped
like a donut and an eclair and our name
Winchell and Duncan as an homage to
Winchell's donuts and Dunkin Donuts to
children they may seem like any other of
the personified edibles running around
the game but their parents are sure to
get a chuckle out of this somewhat
unsubtle play on the whole cops like
doughnuts stereotype generations ears
might be inclined to fixate on some of
the more contemporary references
scattered about the screen in wreck-it
Ralph things like dance dance revelution
Bowser from Super Mario Brothers and the
halo asked soldiers rift on in hero's
duty but there are some background
characters with much longer histories
Frogger Street Fighter and Sonic the
Hedgehog are probably still mainstream
enough to ring a bell for most people
some of the more obscure characters in
the film however include tappers
bowtie-wearing bartender and Qbert and
while fully grown film goers might find
their fingers glued to the pause button
as they scour the screens for these
hidden gems the younger crowd probably
doesn't care about a bunch of 8-bit
oldies even the most obvious game
reference of all in wreck-it Ralph could
be easily missed by anyone who wasn't
around for the glory days of the
earliest arcade systems fix-it felix is
purely a cinematic creation but was
undoubtedly inspired by Donkey Kong
which debuted in 1981 on an arcade
machine that also featured the debut of
jump man otherwise known as Mario Donkey
Kong as a character will still be
familiar to today's device wielding
whippersnappers since he appears in
modern game
like Mario Kart and Super Smash Brothers
so it's probably not too surprising that
his hulking size brute strength and
general officious inspired a lot of
Ralph's physical and personality traits
its fix-it felix is mission and play
style that really bears a striking
resemblance to the old Donkey Kong
though
[Music]
anyhoo what else I'm a wrecker I wrecked
things professionally in both games the
do-gooder is charged with climbing a
large structure while the villain tosses
debris down at them they might not be
exactly the same but well they
practically are it's not until the tail
end of wreckit-ralph that audiences find
out the film features another Disney
Princess to add to the collection but
even after she suited up in a ball gown
vanellope von schweetz handles this fact
very differently than her forebears
sure there are a few theoretical
similarities to the princesses of old
she's been deprived of her title by an
evildoer gets bullied by a bunch of Mean
Girls and is frequently told that her
eccentricities in this case glitches are
troublesome so far so Disney Princess
unlike her peers however vanellope has
no interest in wearing the crown even
Matta for the most part there's nothing
stereotypically princessy about her
she's feisty resourceful determined and
has absolutely no interest in living a
prim life of privilege not only that but
there's nary a love interest inside
either
and while Ralph does help her fulfill
her dream of earning a spot in the big
race she does a lot of the legwork
herself the diet coke and mentos geyser
gag that saves the day in wreck-it Ralph
is based on a real trend that became big
in the mid Ott's after an on-air
demonstration of the effect went viral
subsequently inspiring an episode of
Mythbusters for those who grew up ahead
of the internet age though there was a
much earlier version of the messy
at-home experiment that everyone just
had to try way back when it was the
wintergreen flavored lifesavers that
kids would drop into their soda bottles
to set off a massive liquid eruption
that was just one of the many food item
combination challenges that would get
around by word of mouth in the 90s so
while the candy soda combo trick in
wreck-it Ralph may be a convenient plot
device that kids can shrug their
shoulders at the older crowd might just
get a tinge of nostalgia after seeing it
coming to use
[Music]